welcome back the same day dhs secretary
matt york has confidentially
tallied the binding administration's
so-called progress on the southern
border he shared a much different
message behind closed doors listen to
this leaked audio fox
audio file obtained by fox
if uh if our board is the first line of
defense we're going to lose and this is
unsustainable
we can't continue like this
our people in the field can't continue
and our system isn't built for it
joining me now direct is ken cuccinelli
the former acting deputy secretary for
dhs um were you surprised secretary when
you heard this audio
yeah i was surprised
um
you know sadly i was surprised because
it's the first honest accurate statement
i've heard out of secretary mayorka
since he was sworn in about the border
and but i'm not sure i believe him i
look this is a a guy who'll pander to
the folks in front of him and remember
who he was talking to he was talking to
the border patrol agents that protect
you and me in this country
and honestly he has never cared about
them that goes back to his last
time of service in the department of
homeland security when he famously said
you know the morale of these cbp
officers is of no moment to me he didn't
care then he doesn't care now but he's
talking to them and
you know actions will speak louder than
these words so is he going to follow
through and actually make changes needed
to push these numbers down and to take
the strain off the border patrol agents
who were just getting
you know deluge of 7 000 illegal aliens
a day
you'll remember jay johnson obama's
secretary
uh said that a thousand a day was a
crisis well we're at 7 000 and counting
and it's literally the worst logistical
burden at our border in history
in history ever you know mr secretary
the numbers don't lie july we have the
new numbers 212 000 that's up 13
from june
yeah
yeah it's like a think of it this way we
just finished the olympics it's like
michael phelps breaking his 50-meter
record by two seconds
you know i mean just it's an explosion
it's an absolute explosion they've been
building it up what is the end game here
though i mean because it's clearly out
of control that's the problem you've hit
it on the head there isn't an exit
strategy here they have they told their
base oh open borders we're going to open
the door it'll be great we're going to
get these people registered to vote even
though they're illegal aliens and you
can look at their voting bills on
capitol hill and see that's what they're
trying to do
however
because this is truly unsustainable in
the real world something we told them
over and over and over frankly just had
a federal court order them to restart
the remain in mexico program
and part of what they cited the judge
cited there was mark morgan's testimony
about
how
in the transition from the trump
administration to the biden
administration and over a hundred
meetings with professionals not the
political folks the professionals who
work the border they were told over and
over that exactly what you're seeing
happen is exactly what would happen and
they pressed ahead anyway and now
they've backed themselves into a
political corner that is costing america
security every single day well mr
secretary then we we know that you guys
briefed them we know the state
department briefed them
then you got to ask yourself the
question was this about design and i
think we know the answer to this because
you got a progressive left that has a
policy of open borders they don't
believe anybody is in fact illegal they
don't believe in the legal uh uh
channels that you should disrespecting
the the current immigrants that are here
and then you think about the cuban
people that are fighting in their own
country and they're telling them to just
stay just stay just incredible so you
know
throughout our history we've been just a
beacon of light for those kinds of
oppressed folks and
not disrespecting even the illegal
aliens who are coming on an individual
basis but that's not what they're coming
from right they are not fighting evil
and tyranny and oppression although
sometimes i think we are here
so uh but but it is an incredible
dichotomy it is a terrible policy by the
bite administration it's doing terrible
harm to america especially our poor
people you know mr second american
people see it that's why they're tanking
in the polls on this issue thank you so
much for coming on the program